all right so we're may be recording
right now so yeah we're recording from
the computer so who knows if this is
actually going to work nobody knows and
tonight we will be going over Owens
defense so it seems like a it's a good
one some of the crowd are about to learn
what that is and this was sent in from
so many people but uh so I didn't really
want to cover something that's
considered so dubious but when so many
people request it you just got to give
the people what they want
so for thank you in advance who says
please cover the Owens defense against
1.e4 it's a great counter-attacking
response that was the last one that I
saw and so that's what I will be
covering today so let's get right to it
so Owens defense occurs after the moves
efore and now b6 so already one move in
we know the name of the opening this is
Owens defense and one time I was hanging
out late at night at the club with a lot
of super grandmasters like the top 10 in
the world and they were talking about
this position yeah like the Sinquefield
cup yeah so the players in there they
were talking about this position and the
discussion was about half of them
thought this opening is just really
dubious but it probably equalizes
eventually for black and those also half
of them that just think this move losses
by force so it's a it is kind of a
suspicious opening it's not really doing
too much to address the issues in the
center of course you are going to if I
can draw arrows yeah you can put your
Bishop on b7 and you're going to start
to put pressure on the the e pawn and I
think he is right to say the person that
sent this in that it is a counter
attacking defense I use this as a weapon
against significantly lower rated
players because then they don't know
what to do and already they have to
start thinking and it's only moved one
so that's the reason I like to play this
I played somebody right in 2000 and I
want in like 10 moves so when I play
those people this is this is what I like
to play just to make them think but I
think against the well prepared opponent
you might run into some troubles here
with the black piece
now White's Universal move here there's
really only one move that is played in
this position and that's the move d4
because why not they let you take the
center so you should take it and now
black gets the play Bishop to b7 that
was his whole point and already yeah and
c3 Knight to c3 mm-hm yeah so we'll see
that Knight to c3 is one of the main
moves and Bishop to d3 is the other one
excellent so let's see which one I guess
I'll ask the audience here what would
you guys think at white should play in
this position noticing that the e pawn
is attacked so how would you guys handle
this situation here all right so we got
a suggestion for Knight to c3 which i
think is a sort of the most logical move
you know when you see this right you
just bring out a piece you defend the
center but surprisingly it's not the
most popular Bishop to d3 is actually
more popular but we'll have a look at
this continuation so in lines where the
knight goes to c3 the other option of
course in this position you know if
Knights even go to c3 or d2 and there's
there's some differences so whenever you
are transformed off put your knight on
c3 black's typical plan sort of like in
the nimzo-indian is to play six and
Bishop to b4 so this is kind of like a
hybrid between like the nihms oh and the
Queen's Indian it's it's somewhere in
there but it's an e4 opening so it's
kind of a little bit different and
that's sort of the thing with this
opening it often will transposed all
sorts of openings you might get
structures that are similar to the
French you might get structures that are
similar to the Sicilian so you need to
be a flexible player if you you want to
play this way because you're not
directly contesting the center so White
has all sorts of options and you have to
be ready for just about everything so in
this position black plays C six white
can play a normal move let's just play
Knight to f3 and now Bishop to b4 so you
pin the night and attack the pawn
now one time I was playing somebody
rated about 1200 and in this position
they played Bishop to d2 probably they
don't know my rule never play Bishop to
d2 and this is a good example where that
rule is true you see why this is wrong
why what should black do right and
that's what I did and then yeah then you
played like Bishop d3 and I went here
and then somehow in like five moves from
now he hung his queen like I don't know
how that's possible but that's that's
what happened so like it seems
impossible but it just yeah just took
its Queen and then like i checkmated am
raynathan so yeah this is perfect umm
this is exactly what you're trying to do
you're trying to win that heap on it
sometimes it happens even against okay
1200 it's not bad you know you think
they might feel to see this but okay
let's see so now the threat of taking
the pawn is real so we need to defend it
one more time Bishop to d3 makes a lot
of sense even there are even air in
degrees it makes a lot of sense so now
Knight to f6 black continues to put
pressure here so remember the knight is
pinned so now black is attacking it
twice and white is only directly
defending it one time and in this
opening in general white wants to keep
his pawn on e4 he doesn't want a hurry
to play a move like 'if I've because if
you play e5 you are giving certain
squares away the black might be able to
use so he could put his knight on either
one of those squares here in this
position and the pawns are perfect on e4
and d4 because then control basically
the whole fifth rank so those are
excellent pawns so in almost every line
white is going to try to hold on to his
pawn and keep the pond there so Erin how
would you defend the pond Queen to e2 an
excellent move okay so yes we just keep
it there and alright now you have to
decide what you're going to do here okay
so black plays d5
the other option was to play C 5 but d5
is more popular and again your
attacking efore that's what black should
do he just keeps attacking e4 and I
think the move that most people would
play here automatically is actually a
mistake
'if I've is a mistake yeah he should
take here but we'll try to understand
look at e5 and now you're probably just
expecting okay he'll just retreat at
some point black Oh Castle maybe he'll
play c5 get his other night out but he
actually doesn't have to retreat in this
position he can go forward Knight to e4
this is black short point and anything
that white does here it will be a
concession notice first of all that you
can't take this night this would be a
very bad move this just just blunders
upon because now black takes and
wherever the knight moves we take on d4
and then we're attacking 5 and c3 and
you've got a lot of problems already
here you're down upon and blacks doing
great so that would be just a mistake
there is in these lines often the option
of just castling which is a gambit
obviously black can take here and I only
mention it briefly because these sorts
of positions they occur all the time in
the Owens defense and sometimes in
certain you know strange offbeat French
defenses you do have some compensation
while it gets really fantastic pieces
this Bishop really probably belongs over
on e7 so it's a bit out of play but you
are up upon so play normally would
continue they attack the pond and either
the queen of the bishop protects the
deep on and you get you know a very
interesting game and okay I just mention
it just because sometimes sometimes it's
possible so you do want to keep that in
mind but the main move here is Bishop to
d2 and white can say okay I'll take the
bishops and in such a position black has
the two bishops he is the plan of
playing c5 in the near future he should
be careful about castling because you
got to worry about Greek gifts that
might be looming in the position so okay
but uh yeah mainly to another option for
black hair is to put his Bishop back on
e7 before you play the move c5 the
reason being if you play C five
immediately see if they can play a3 and
you don't want to give up the bishops
and you can go back to a5 and this is
fine and this has been played before but
really in this Bishop belongs over here
on e7 so okay so that's why if we go
back to the position in which black
played e5 the main move is to take and
black has three ways to take back and
they've all been played the most common
is to take back with the knight but
taking back with the Queen also is very
possible you get sort of like a
Scandinavian structure so people don't
like the Scandinavian might want to look
up those lines but more popular is to
take with the night and attack the
knight on c3 excellent so white could
Castle you can do the same sort of
gambit or more often you can play Bishop
to d2 hmm and so black gets to ruin the
pawn structure and the bishop must
retreat well I suppose you could go to
a5 or d6 but you probably want to be on
e7
where you control some of these dark
squares just to make sure the knight
stays out of there because once you
castle will give way to move here so
whenever black castles he does have to
worry about an attack so white is really
he's like oh look at all these all these
pieces you know I can get all these
pieces into the attack and I can go try
to checkmate you really fast so black
doesn't have to castle it is you know
it's one of the two main moves here but
also you could play Knight to d7 and c5
first and just not not tell you where
the King is going quite yet but castling
is fine there's no no great gift at the
moment based off the fact that you have
g5 under control is black so alright so
that's that's one possibility and so
both sides can say okay I kind of like
this position when you play the omens
this is one of the critical lines you
know if you like this position you did
ruin White's pawn structure
you will probably very shortly play a
four a five to try to get rid of this
weakness and normally white tries to
like do make you go to sleep over here
on the queenside is moving all the stuff
over there and then when you're not
looking attacks you on the kingside and
checkmate too so watch out for that but
uh okay we'll go back and look at the
other way to play and then you can
compare the two variations and see which
one you like for yourself okay so we go
back to sort of the starting position
and again the epon is attacked and now
we'll go over the more popular move
Bishop to d3 okay again black plays
ecigs and if you play Knight to c3 then
we'll play Bishop to b4 and wait so
we'll get a transposition to sort of
what we just saw
so instead white has a flexible move
Knight to f3
all right you thought of that all right
and now Bishop to b4 doesn't make sense
because white just plays c3 and in this
variation he's probably gonna play c3
anyway and as we'll see as we go along
that Knight often goes to D 2 instead of
c3 alright now what to do is black this
is normally the time where black decides
to attack the center so you could play
d5 which is very uncommon but it was
seen in the famous game France Machuca
2016 you know that game it happened in
the Monday night mayhem tournament I've
done everything I can to sabotage Danny
Machuca week after week he just shows up
and he keeps winning the tournament
I'll make him play three people at once
some there's some victims in the room
from that he won every single game to
get one point yeah the good thing is
there's no camera so even if you dunk
nobody nobody's ever going to know I've
made him play with time odds but the
only thing that's ever worked is just
playing him myself
that's the only way to shut him down and
I made him play the Owens defense and
then yeah I got to win and here he
played d5 and then I played a 5 and his
knight never found a good place to go so
more common is c5
and so you might Castle which is fine I
guess you know and you'll get a sort of
an open Sicilian type structure this is
a very possible way to play and you know
so a continuation might go like this and
then the bishop will probably go to c5
and the knight will go either to f6 but
Knight to e7 is not so bad either
with the knight on e7 you are you know
you know white thread of blank e5 at
some point isn't going to attack your
knight and from e7 the knight will be
preparing the d5 break for black so this
is a fine this should be sort of an
equal position for both sides but very
playable it's if you you know you like
the Sicilian that's maybe that's the way
you want to play this position is white
but more common is to keep the pawn on
d4 how do you do that you know yeah how
do you do it c3 excellent move let's go
back c3 perfect yeah so if you if you
just take on d4 I'll take back with my
pond okay fair enough
now Knight to f6 and then what should we
play here is white what do you think the
most common move is
Bishop g5 isn't actually I think the
third most common move but yeah it is
playable
yeah can you go fight Bishop e7 or I can
play h6 okay but the most common move is
actually Queen to e2 so again right
we're just protecting the pond also it's
possible to play e5 but again we're
giving away squares and our big
advantage is white is this huge space
advantage so we really want those pawns
to stay where they are which is why
Queen to e2 makes a lot of sense here
and it's the most common move and now we
can blunder the most common move here is
Bishop to e7 and we'll try to understand
why you might be thinking okay just
attack the center again that seems good
you're attacking the center again and if
we trade here sometimes we'll get to
play Knight to b4 and then we get to
take your bishop that looks good but
this is actually a blunder now I talked
about this opening before in my top 10
efore video so some people were in that
room so let's see if they can remember
what is the move that white can play in
this position
all right now give a big hint there's a
queen on the same file as the black king
yes yeah so d5 is just a fantastic move
here
obviously you can't take this you can
write the knight will die so what if I
go here though oh just what just keep
pushing it yeah excellent and so this
will just win a piece the other option
is to get out of town and go to a5 but
but but what
but b4 by white yeah move I would never
consider I never I never never saw that
one coming
okay yeah it doesn't work okay but
there's there's a lot of boobs but I
mean c4 will illustrate the point well
enough these two people are just sort of
spectators over here the bishop has been
shut down the Knights out of place
White's Center is now tremendous in the
future we might be able to do this and
this and then just crush you so this
would be a very bad mistake by black so
that's something to work out for but now
with the bishop on e7 if you play this
way first d5 is not a threat because
we'll take it a bunch of times because
this move doesn't come with check so we
can take the pawn with anything we want
so it should be seven and white normally
castles makes a lot of sense
now the knight comes out to c6 and so we
do have a threat I'll make a you know
useless move over here for white to
illustrate the positional threat black
wants to take this and play Knight to b4
and he's going to get your Bishop and
then then do it
then take the e4 pawn right yeah I mean
so yeah you could you know protect it
with your knife you get a position like
this but this is one of your big
attackers here is white if we go back to
the position here without h3 this is one
of your biggest attackers on the castle
King because whenever black castles King
side you're thinking about playing e5
shooing the night away and you have this
bishop on this nice diagonal and
sometimes you'll sacrifice on h7 and
then checkmate the King so that would be
nice so that's why black endeavors to go
and get that fish up so most often white
will stop him from doing that you can
play the move a 3 so this prevents any
Knight to be 4 in the future and blacks
next move might shock you I don't know
how old you are but this might be a
really shocking move ok do I want to
close your eyes
it's Knight to a5 did that shock you
no you saw that one coming really what's
the knight doing out there isn't white
just about to play b4 and kick your
night away and you'll feel silly is that
about to happen
it is weird yes hmm well b4 might be
able to attack my knight in the future
but for the moment we're thinking about
jumping into b3 so if you played before
we play 93 then we're feeling fine so
white will try to protect b3 Knight B to
d2
so yes so these are the lines where the
night goes to d2 and now the only reason
to make sense of the move Knight to a5
is the next tactical point Black has a
tactical move here that's the
justification for putting the knight out
there because White's next move is b4 if
you do nothing and then you got to move
the knight back and then people will
laugh at you right you don't tell people
to laugh at you but black hair can play
c4 that shocked you as well you just you
get it what's the point
excellent yeah if the knight takes the
pawn we do this and then what yeah then
anything takes this guy okay excellent
so that's the point
so normally white doesn't want to give
up his epon you know II for d4 or is big
Trump here so Bishop - C - yeah makes
sense and now what to do the most
flexible move here for black and this
will sort of get us to our starting
position for the game that we're going
to show is Queen to c7 one of the the
points of this move is not only are we
we're not cancelling yet because we
don't want you to know which way we're
going to go and black can even cancel
Queen side in this these sorts of
positions most often he goes Kings side
but we're keeping the option open and
with the Queen on c7 if you ever play d5
we can play the movie e5 in the e pawn
is protected so here is sort of the
starting point thank you guys for for
watching and being here in person spent
a lot of fun this one who knows maybe
this is a good format maybe we'll do
this again
maybe it won't be recorded and nobody's
watching this on the internet right now
but
yeah I'm just talking you know some
people are listening somewhere but yeah
so keep sending in your your openings
that you want to see hit like share
subscribe and tell me what you think of
this format is it better with or without
my beautiful face on the screen you let
me know thanks for watching